sieht wirklich ein problem auf die
mutter hasst die ruinen
ab und zu darf ich mit fünf geht darum
dass ein meteorit auf die erde zurast
und buck das wiesel dass wir schon aus
einem früheren filmen kennen
erkennt das und kennt eine lösung muss
die anderen säugetieren davon überzeugen
ihm zu helfen und dann ist es im grunde
wie bei den meisten anderen ice age
filmen auch sie wandern dann irgendwohin
und treffen dort auf eine situation die
sie lösen müssen
kein mensch braucht 15 die ersten vier
filme waren aber lustig genug dass man
da schon noch ein machen konnte
allerdings angeht so viele
naturkatastrophen schon gesehen und
jetzt eben noch den drohenden
meteoriteneinschlag ich habe das gefühl
alle witze die mit den figuren gehen
habe ich jetzt schon mindestens einmal
gesehen
und zwar ist das kletter immer diese
haselnuss irgendwo vermitteln möchte und
ganz am anfang stellt sich heraus dass
die harte nuss der schlüssel für einem
raumschiff ist könnte es also die ganze
zeit mit diesem raumschiff unterwegs
kann es aber natürlich nicht steuern
das ist alles sehr sehr lustig und
außerdem sortierte auf die weise
nebenbei noch so ein bisschen das
planetensystem
sehr gut an ice age ist dass die figuren
einfach charmant sind und dass die
figuren sich auch so ein bisschen
weiterentwickelt haben aber immer noch
die gleichen internen rangeleien und
machtspiele haben es tatsächlich als
würde man noch mal mit seiner elften
klasse unterwegs sein sich diesen film
anzugucken
gerade in erfüllung gegangen meine auch
der film hat wirklich ein paar viel zu
kitschige momente als er ist schon auch
sehr lustig aber dazwischen es ist immer
wieder viel zu viel größer und viel zu
viel herzlichen in die augen
es werden auch immer mehr figuren
allmählich ist es ein bisschen wie und
frieden mit tieren und wenn man die
vorherige filme nicht gesehen hat es ist
glaube ich gar nicht so einfach die alle
einzuordnen ein hübscher ich bin brot
ich nehme an alle die die ersten filme
gesehen haben wollen den auch gucken und
das kann man auch gut machen
der ist für eine fünfte fortsetzung
schon noch ganz solide aber zeigt auch
dass die fünfte fortsetzung von etwas
nicht immer so originell ist wie die
vier davor ich hasse lama buckman stinkt
seid gegrüßt säugetiere der shangri la
der shangri la empfängt
das ist der typ der uns reden und so ein
neues thema wir werden alle sterben